rising food costs higher energy bills
record petrol prices increasing
inflation and an end to furlough
and the universal credit uplift
tonight
cost of living what's got to give
this is the great debate
[Applause]
on the great debate we get to the heart
of the issue dominating the headlines
this week as the chancellor prepares to
set out how he plans to run the
country's finances in the months to come
how are people coping with pressures on
their own budget
and what if anything can rishi sunak do
to solve the crisis
our viewers panel drawn from around the
country and beyond will share their
views they'll have their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio guests
joining us in the studio this week lord
byrd founder of the big issue
director of the institute for fiscal
studies paul johnson
ella whelan journalist and co-convener
of the academy of ideas festival
and personal finance expert emmanuel
asuko
the big question facing them all tonight
cost of living
what's got to give
let's go straight to the wall to our
viewers panel and let's talk to denise
briggenshaw in essex denise
what's your take on this
well i was followed in the first
lockdown
then i was made redundant
then at christmas just go on i
was diagnosed with um disabilities
i'm 54 i've paid in all my life my taxes
i've got my degrees and so about it's
not still got all my
so i'm not going to put my heating on
because they've just told me that's
gonna go from 70 pound a month to 160
so
i will now be wearing more jumpers in
fact that's what i do i've got blankets
on my sofa
um because i'm just too scared it's put
my heating on and it's just not the
heating it's the electric as well
and i just feel really frustrated
because there isn't a choice i you know
i'm stuck i've got chronic pain i'm i'm
stuck at home i'm stuck on universal
credit
and i don't think the government's in
the real world you know the people voted
for the government
they're supposed to the people value for
them they're supposed to work for us you
know but i just feel they're completely
abandoned the reality of what we go
through
thank you for that denise a dose of
reality there let's go
to stephen fairley stephen you're in
bathgate in west lothian
that's correct good evening panel um my
question is is this government going to
help bring the cost of living down or
are we on our own
why are you asking that stephen
when you say on our own what do you
mean well i just feel as if you know i
think we are indeed on our own i think
the government
needs to look at stripping back on
existing policies to help on housing
energy
child care and the rising cost of food
inflation's on the y when the rise wages
is rising but not uh it's a slower rate
than inflation
and we've got labour shortages and i
think
from my own personal experience i think
we are indeed on our own i think it's
there's a big gap and it's sad to see
especially with the person who was just
talking before me
you well in fact denise was saying that
she just feels that nobody really
understands is that your feeling too
absolutely i think um the government uh
even local councils
i mean local councils uh are given a lot
of law you know they're given a lot of
laws they can pass
um taxations on the you know the you
know the council taxes and they're
they're not listening neither so it's
not just the government but it's also in
the councils as well could
could step in and help people within the
constituency
stephen thank you let's take your
question and put it to our studio
guests stephen asks will the government
bring down the cost of living or are we
on our own
john bird
well i think the government has to bring
down the stat the cost of living
i think the
uh i mean i talk to the government every
now and then
and they keep saying they put an
enormous amount of money
in the emergency
and they're in some senses reply
implying that they don't have the money
for the recovery so we have to look at
this
as a recovery period so therefore they
have to carry on making the investment
because if they don't
then there will be an enormous hit
on the social services on our schools on
our uh nhs and all the other parts of
society
and so therefore they have to spend to
save and that is a very very difficult
uh
thing to ask the government when they've
spent over about half a trillion pounds
on the emergency we have to get through
to the recovery so our colleague there
is exactly right
okay
emmanuel aluco um
what are you hearing from your clients
because you're a finance expert they
come to you for advice yep they come to
me for advice and they definitely feel
like they're on their own and you know
we have to look at ways to try and make
it work for them i think for the average
person we've seen discounts on on stamp
duty for people that want to buy a house
we've seen ben we've seen pensions now
being able to pass without paying any
tax we've seen
so many so much support for people who
want to make money but yet so much cuts
when it comes to people who really need
it most and i feel that the government
needs to definitely do more to help the
poorest and i feel they're more
concerned about their votes than they
are about the people they should really
care about so your point is really not
just
privation as it were but also unfairness
i'm fairness completely they're they're
they're targeting their we've seen over
the last 12 to 18 months the support and
the help has gone to people who are
making money as opposed to people who
need the support
paul johnson um
this is the world that you spend your
life in
do you recognize this picture
yeah i mean we've had uh big cuts in
benefits over the last uh four or five
years it's not just the failure to keep
the 20 pound uplift in universal credit
the value of benefits has been cut by
something like 12 billion pounds over
the last five or six years so there's
certainly been a push down on the
incomes of people right at the bottom of
the distribution that said there's a lot
more people in work than there were four
or five years ago and the minimum wage
is rising quite fast so there is some
offsetting impact there what we're
seeing right now of course is a push-up
in prices that we haven't seen actually
for really quite a long time with
inflation heading up towards four or
even five percent now that's not the
levels some of us can remember in the
1970s of 20 but that is still a big
increase in costs and to the extent that
it's coming through things like fuel
bills which you heard about uh just
there that has a much bigger effect on
people on low incomes than it does on
people on high income so even if
benefits go up in line with inflation
that's still not going to be enough to
make up for that additional cost for
people who are on benefits
what do you make of it the government
not doing enough
or well they're they seem to be playing
two games at the same time that are
contradicting one another so you know
whether it be the cut in the 20 pounds
for universal credit or the end of the
furlough scheme the message seems to be
from the government that we're coming
out of this pandemic and as john says
you know all emergency measures are now
to be relinquished uh that's that's sort
of what they're suggesting at the same
time we've got this sword of damocles
held over our head in the form of plan b
we've got now suggestion of future if
not lock down some kind of restriction
which tells everyone at home watching or
well i better get ready for another
experience of what we've had in the last
18 months which means as denise was
talking about redundancies changes in
people's ability to access you know the
finer things in life not just the basics
but actually have some leisure time do
something nice with your life and you
know enjoy life and they can't keep
playing that double game it seems at the
moment that the government wants to
pretend like they're um doing something
but holding this threat over us of
increased covert restrictions which we
know are devastating for people's
standards of living all right let me
come back to the wall let's cut let me
let's talk to
wayne taylor wayne uh you're a customer
support advisor and i think you're in
bradford what do you make of this
question about
whether the government is doing enough
leaving us alone what do you think
um
to answer your actual initial question
of what the um
program is based on what's going to give
um it sat well it's me where i'm going
to give
um because
i do not think the government ever does
enough i think the government that they
always look after themselves they will
always fill their own pockets with what
they want and they do not i don't think
any government whether it's conservative
or labour actually cares about the
average man
my staff trevor i am not an average guy
on the street i earn a good living i
have a i have a good wage and i love the
final things in life
but this past two to three weeks i am
now when i go shopping i am picking
um off the show i've got to check what
i'm buying and it's just i
spent 95 pounds this week on a shop
and that was literally for food to make
the meals i went i didn't get any
like the likes of biscuits but like nice
things that you want to be able to make
and what have you
and on petrol
12 months ago it cost me 48 pounds to
fill my car i went to philip on sunday
and it cost me 65 hours to fill my car
that's in 12 months that is a 17 pound
rise and that's just shocking okay wayne
you are clearly feeling the squeeze
let's see how widely that view is
reflected let's go to the wall uh let's
talk to our viewers panel and i'm going
to ask you all
where you are on this those who think
that we are now getting to the place
where the squeeze is so extreme
government has to do something we expect
something from mr sunak on wednesday who
thinks that the squeeze has got to the
extreme place um
those who agree
that it's gone too far
looking at what your
the situation is today
hearing what you're hearing today who
thinks that between now and april
national insurance
rise kicks in who thinks that they are
going to have to make some actual
changes to their spending patterns and
what they do between now and april those
who think you're going to have to make a
change
okay well i think that's a pretty clear
signal to the chancellor that right now
the country thinks that something
dramatic is going to have to to give
emmanuel
is that
do you what do you think people can do
about this
it's a hard question because
everyone's finances is personal to them
and i think we have to reassess i'm i'm
speaking to clients and saying you know
we're coming up to christmas we've got
we can't see this christmas as we've
seen other years we have to look at
cutting back maybe look at a 30
reduction really look at what's really
important i think we have to we're going
to have to make changes we can't live
how we lived before because we haven't
experienced this type of climate this
type of environment before and so
changes have to be done and it's hard
because
especially after the year we've had and
the people the loved ones that we've
lost christmas you really want to go out
and you really want to enjoy it but i
just feel like that this is not the year
to do that paul johnson do you think
this is
a temporary blip or are we going to have
to get used to the whole belt tightening
thing
well we've sort of got used to it in the
last 10 years and more don't forget the
last 10 years have seen the slowest
growth
in income and earnings that probably
we've had in 200 years so there's a
sense of which this isn't terribly new
what what the bit that is new about this
is that it's prices going up rather what
we've seen over the past decades prices
going up a little bit and wages going up
um about the same rate but but really
slow growth we
up until 2010 we got used to getting
better off year after year after year
and that sort of stopped for the last
decade so in that sense it isn't that
new but it is different because we're
seeing price of fuel price of petrol uh
price of um food and so on going up for
some people um let's be for some people
this is going to be a great year or two
because we're some bits of the labor
market some people on earnings are
seeing genuinely seeing quite big uh
increases uh but in other areas they're
not and the labor market's really
struggling and i think that's one of the
things that the chancellor's going to be
wrestling with and we all need to
acknowledge as emmanuel was saying
everyone's different and
circumstances are different but actually
it's more different at the moment
because the economy is adjusting to
covert it's adjusting to brexit the big
changes which normally takes several
years are happening over a few months
okay so something real is happening
and we are going to have to work out
what to do about it we've been talking
about the cost of living crisis but is
it being felt equally across the
generations
that's coming up next
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the cost of living and
asking what's got to give
and it's not just what's got to give but
who
i'd like to start with ron knox who is
in
sutton in surrey
hello ron
good evening trevor good evening pamela
it's a time when the cost of living is
rising at an unbelievable rate
particularly in staples like food and
energy
the government's answer seems to be to
promise high wage growth for everyone
although details about how that might be
achieved or very sketchy my question is
is the suspension of a triple lock a
betrayal of pensioners
uh but that's quite an important
question and i want to come in
to
you guys and ask you ron's question is
the suspension of the triple lock a
betrayal of pensioners um
paul
what do you think
no um would be my straightforward answer
to that on this particular occasion
the
headline rate of earnings this year went
up something like seven or eight percent
just because there was a huge dip
last year so if you kept to the triple
lock you'd have given pensioners vastly
more than anyone else in the population
was getting uh and just because of a
statistical anomaly about the way these
things
are measured so certainly for this year
to revert to the higher of inflation and
two and a half percent was quite
appropriate arguably over the longer
term there's tooth waiting look at this
what the triple lock does is gradually
ratchet up the level of the state
pension relative to prices and earnings
and that might be something you want to
do though the triple lock is a pretty
random way
of doing it but to have kept it this
year and had a huge windfall for
pensioners um simply because of a
statistical artifact would in my view
actually have been absurd okay well i
want to reassure
viewers that though i am myself a
pensioner i am completely neutral here
but let me come back to you ron what
what do you think about uh paul's answer
that actually it would have been really
unfair
people like you and me would have got
what an eight eight percent rise
what do you think the point the point
in my understanding the point of the
triple lock
was to guarantee that this vital state
benefit would continue to rise every
year
and you know the three measures of the
triple lock
inflation average earnings growth or a
flat 2.5 rise
pensioners were promised that the
highest of those three measures would be
implemented and i would only say it's
also very poor politics i mean the
elderly form a big percentage of
conservative voters and probably those
who voted for brexit so boris johnson
needs to be very careful i am sure he is
listening right now ron and he has he
has taken your point let's let's see
what a younger voter thinks about this
i'm going to come to uh farah khan
in crawley in west sussex um pharah i
think you will have heard what ron had
to say
what do you think do you buy do you
accept his point
i think that um everyone in society is
equally important um but i also believe
that the government needs to do more and
remember
that tomorrow is in their hands today i
think that the government should look at
the future which are young people and
this means that i think um this we can
reduce tuition fees we should
be reducing commuting costs and focusing
on leveling up policy and supply-side
policy on education so that spaces can
be created for young people to excel
professionally
okay i'm going to ask you two to try and
persuade each other but before we come
to that emmanuel where do you stand on
this do you think that we are
coddling
the old folks
at the expense of the future
um
i do i do think we are i think that when
you think about you're off the show
when you think about what young people
have had to go through in regards to i i
mean young people every day who can't
who struggle to even dream of owning a
property with what's happened over time
we see the cost of university compared
to
when we when we start to actually look
at what what young people have to go
through compared to what other
generations have gone through i think
you know we have to try and have more
policies to really encourage them to
give them the hope to give them an idea
that they can actually own something
they can have ownership of their lives
and i thought right now
that's not the case i feel a lot of
young people right now so they have to
go with the flow and wherever they can
take and maybe that's just because the
current climate but i think the
government really needs to give people
their identity
well listen i'm not quite young anymore
but i think that the you know maybe
speaking on behalf of the younger
section there is i think we have to
reject this generational very toxic way
of framing a generational war in
politics particularly when it comes to
provisions for people in society i mean
i have to disagree with the idea that
it's young people that have been hit
worse throughout the pandemic i mean
we're talking in a political context in
which
elderly people have been for years now
denigrated whether it be talks of
describing them as bed blockers about in
relation to the nhs you know the
suggestion that your granny needs to
downsize from her house that she's had
from you know 30 40 years to be able to
make room for a younger generation ron i
i could see you smiling as ella was
speaking and it sort of feels like you
agree persuade pharah
talk to pharah and persuade her
i i totally accept farrah's point that
uh young people's development is is key
to to the economy
however
um
people who have worked all their lives
and built up considerable amount of um
you know
financial resource and so on
are now finding that things are getting
very tough and it just simply isn't
deserved
and the the
average age is is getting higher isn't
it and it's going to be
um
a question that won't go away it's going
to be
increasing in volume
you know forevermore all right aphara
persuade ron that he is basically
uh making a case that is
unfair on young people
well if we look at what the pandemic did
to young people we can clearly see that
um a lot is wrong with the current
system and we need to just look at um
the fact that young people are not at
university but we're still paying their
full university fee we just need to look
at how young people are treated fiscally
when it comes to commuting prices why
are they so high young people don't have
that money i think we need to understand
that everyone in society is valid and to
receive help if they need it but i think
we have to focus on um if the government
is serious about creating and
maintaining a high skill economy we need
to work on creating that and that should
start now and i yeah i really think that
we all need to focus on everyone within
society
but we should be prioritizing young
people as well
okay thank you both very much let me
let's come to the wall let's
let's accept that uh you know we could
be thinking about growth but the truth
is that mr sunek will tell us on
wednesday that there is no magic money
tree there's limitations and ron knox
says that actually a promise is being
broken and that actually he should stick
to his the promise
those who agree with ron knox that
actually the triple lock should stay in
place as
it was promised
okay
there's not a lot of hands there who
think that actually
that there's a few people there's quite
a about 20 25 percent those who think
that actually uh what emmanuel and
pharah have been saying is uh and that
uh paul johnson said that actually
it's time to make a change who who
agrees with them
i think a few a few more hands i i think
most people want to leave this one to mr
sunak but we'll see what he says
next
will more money for the nhs mean less
cash for other public services
the cost of living what's got to give
that's our topic on the great debate
the chancellor will announce a six
billion pound cash injection for the nhs
this week to provide millions more
checks scans and procedures
but rishi sunak is facing called for
even more money for health with waiting
lists at a record high and tens of
thousands of covered 19 cases reported
every single day
we'll hear from our viewers panel on
this in a moment but first i'm joined by
professor john appleby director of
research and chief economist at the
independent health tink think tank the
nuffield trust
john
is the money that we hear that the
chancellor's going to shower in the nhs
enough
that's a very big question
well just the 6 billion refers to
capital money
the nhs over the last few years has been
spending about
uh seven or eight billion a year on
capital we don't know quite whether he's
just carved up that money into um some
specific things to do with diagnostics
and so on
whether it be enough that's a big open
question um
the choice is ours in a sense
uh how much do we want to spend
we could spend all of our wealth on
health care at some level
um
so but that means less spending on other
things
so i think the question is open
is there any limit to how much money we
can pour into the nhs i mean some people
would say that what's happening now is
it's just
sucking money in
well um
at the moment we spend about uh
one-tenth of our entire gdp on health
care that's public and private about
very roughly seven and a half eight
percent of gdp is on the nhs and the
rest is is private health care including
things you know buying pills from boots
and so on
um that's a that's a large amount of
money uh it's not out of line with other
countries
we're about middle of the pack for
our eu colleagues uh eu neighbors
the us is a bit of an outlier with about
or
almost verging on 20 of of its gdp on
health care
so um yes it does suck in money um
we keep inventing new things to do to
people and
health care spending is one of the sort
of spending preferences as we get richer
along with education
i i think i personally i think we're
some way off
where we'll end up as it were in terms
of spending on health care i can
certainly foresee us spending uh up
easily up to 20 on health care of our of
our national wealth
and
do you think that we could
use that money elsewhere or is it just
just a way of things
well you ask an economist uh you know
show me a benefit i'll show you a cost
as it were there's always a trade-off
here
so we could spend that money on other
things um
you know we could spend much more money
on education in this country
um
and it's a very it's a very tricky thing
with public spending who's making the
decisions here so
you know we wouldn't be having this
conversation about coffee we don't have
a minister of coffee who's setting a
budget for how much we spend on coffee
but because it's public money and we
gather taxes somebody somewhere in the
system i.e the government has to make a
decision about the next three four years
about how much we spend on health care
so we have to think about these things
and they're very they're very hard
things to think about in terms of you
know the trade-offs that we'll have to
make okay john um thank you so much for
that making making it so clear that's
really helpful
now we have an economist in the studio
but i'm going to come to him after going
to our viewers panel
and i am going to ask alan reevy
alan what are your thoughts on this
question
the amount that we spend on the nhs
well it's probably starving the other
public sector services like education as
we've just heard
uh the development of infrastructure and
policing is something which is certainly
needs looked at
um so the health service seems to be
just a bottomless pit
and there's just no no plug in it um i
think the pandemic
um
brought a lot of things into light we
had no ppe we didn't have the money for
ppe
then these nightingale hospitals just
suddenly sprung up
so i think it's possibly a management
management of money issue and that's
richie sunak
okay and you've got a question that
comes out of that for our studio
is the nhs responsible for starving the
other public sector services of funding
okay
let's come back to studio
alan asks is the nhs responsible for
starving other public sector services of
funding
well we have the person the perfect
person to answer that question paul
johnson
well public uh spending on public
services is in the end down to
government so the nhs could cost all
that it does at the moment and we could
have more money for other public
services if government and electorate
were willing to have higher taxes and
spend more on other things but the thing
about the nhs is that it takes about
four pounds in every 10 of spending on
public services at the moment and that's
up from considerably less than three
pounds in every 10 just 20 years ago so
it's becoming a bigger and bigger part
of everything that government does and
that's partly because um
when spending's going up spending on
health goes up faster than everything
else and of course in the austerity
years spending everything else went down
while spending on health continued to
rise we have a
just to make that point yet again we
have a choice about how much of that
money goes on health how much it goes on
other things and how much we're willing
to pay
for it now very often people say look
very often in the uk we we want european
standards of public services with
american levels of tax well you can't
have that you either have european
public services and european tax and yes
they do typically which is typically
considerably more than here so that
higher taxes and more money on public
services or we can decide to be a low
tax economy but if we're a low tax
economy we're also going to get low
public service okay john bird you're a
legislator
i'm not well i'm in the house of lords
and i look at the government's
legislation but i'm not in the
government
i think the whole argument has been
skewed and it's been skewed for a
considerable period of time
in 2010
the uh the austerity government the
coalition government decided to cut all
sorts of parts of of the apparatus
supplying the money that they gave local
authorities they were looking to save
seven to nine percent they end up saving
one and a half percent but the damage
they did to this country led the
national health service to become the
biggest social sponge that's ever ever
been created we have got a situation
because of the lack of educational uh
investment in education the lack of
investment in in a high-wage economy the
lack of uh money around social services
it's what it has you've turned the
national health service into a social
sponge to soak up all of the problems
that have been left by the government's
cutting austerity so if you really want
if we really want to do something we
need to reform the national health
service so it doesn't have to pick up
the tab for poverty because people going
into the national health service are
people often who are there because of
poverty
i'm going to come back to our viewers
and i want to talk to gareth kerns in
bromley
gareth i think you have a view about the
spending on the nhs
yeah
we can't afford to do without it because
it is big it is big
it is therefore able to mobilize
economies of scale which means it gets
really good value for money it gets
things cheaper drugs etc gets things
cheaper compare it to america it does it
cheaper and if you compare to america it
actually produces better results on just
about every level apart from perhaps i
think cancer recover i think cancer
recovery americans are doing something
better but on just about every other
outcome
we do better and we do better for less
money we're not paying dividends and we
get those economies of scale okay gareth
ella do you buy gareth's argument well
that we you know all the
the doing down of the nhs which i agree
with in a lot of ways in terms of it has
become as and john says a bit of a
sponge you know we forget that the idea
of a social and collective provision of
healthcare for everyone free at the
point of entry is a is a thing that i
politically believe in and that many
people believe in um it's something to
be proud of but the one of the questions
is you'd be forgiven for thinking that
the nhs was swimming in money because of
all the cash that's been thrown at it
and you look and see that the there's a
crisis in wages and cleaners who we've
shown throughout the pandemic provider
they get overlooked a lot but provide
one of the most basic and important
roles for howard hospital runs properly
of nurses of midwives i mean something
that i know a little bit about fertility
care for women in this country is
abysmal it's you know a postcode lottery
like many services emanuel should the
nhs get more money without
extensive reform um no simple answer i
think is is more about efficiencies i
think we have to look at the policies
behind it where the money's going what's
being done i don't think there's enough
accountability money just gets spinning
i don't feel people are held accountable
and there's no okay we made this mistake
let's not do it again it seems like it
repeats itself year on year and until we
start to actually have efficiencies
where they actually publish where this
money is going who's accountable what
changes are going to be done to ensure
that they're going to look after the
money and resources that they're given i
don't think we should be pouring any
more into it after the break
more money for the lowest earners
but who's going to pay for it
welcome back what's got to give to help
the cost of living and what can the
chancellor do about it in the budget
that's a topic of tonight's great debate
on wednesday rishi sunak will confirm an
increase to the national living wage of
more than six percent
while it could also be an end to the
freeze of public sector wages there's no
doubt that both of those things could
help families struggling with food
petrol and energy prices
but how can the government and
businesses pay for it
we're joined now by tony earnshaw in
newcastle tony you have a business sir
what's your answer how are you going to
deal with this
well
good evening we've been in business now
for nearly 18 years and um we know that
prices generally increase every year we
build into our contractor three percent
increase year one year
as you just said this year the increase
just on weeds alone
could be or is point six percent
um
many businesses out there are still
trying to bounce back from the pandemic
if businesses have been closed for many
months
and nearly the whole of the whole of a
half of 2020 and sort of to put the
owners on businesses and to expect them
to be able to put wages up so
significantly
at such short notice
and it's quite a burden
so tony what um what happens do you just
lose people
well there's already shortage we know
that
and
we know that some businesses can't even
reopen they can't win the kitchens we
know that by putting and buying by the
wages going up that also increases
inflation now we're all going to pay for
this whether it's a glass of wine
whether it's
food we order whether it's fuel i mean i
have a fleet of um just under 50
vehicles and the fuel prices have gone
through the roof
so
i mean to me
it's just a small screen they're putting
up the wages the government and in turn
taxes go off and it's a weird input of
taxes okay obviously tony i think you
have a question for our studio
yeah question is can businesses really
afford to increase wages after the
korvik pandemic
tony earnshaw newcastle asks can
businesses really afford to increase
wages after the covet 19 pandemic
emmanuel
a lot of my business clients are
struggling they are trying to to get
back and i think what happens as i said
was that now they're going to have to
increase prices if they if they increase
wages they're going to have to keep
increased prices which then in turn
increases inflation so i think we have
to be careful when we when we put that
pressure especially after what we've
been through to then put an additional
burden on on businesses with with such
short notice
okay
ella what do you think well i mean we've
been talking a lot understandably about
the pandemic and its effects but we have
to remember that the issue of
particularly productivity in this
country has been uh has been dire for i
think actually paul mentioned it's been
dire for decades now and there is no
quick fix magic pill to this i mean a
few more pennies in people's pockets in
relation to raising the living wages
welcome if you know as people are in
dire strains but it's certainly not the
solution i think we have to flip this
and start talking about how we promote
you know it's been a relatively negative
discussion about how we manage with less
and instead we should be talking about
how we promote growth how we promote
wealth in the context of a government
that's obsessed with cutting and
tightening it's about not just in
relation to benefits or taxes or things
like that but also with the kind of
green agenda that says that growth and
development is a bad thing that people
having more um is a is a negative thing
it says we made a virtue of the fact
that we should be having less consuming
less and so that in that context is it
any wonder why people are so hostile to
the and in particular businesses are so
hostile to the idea of taking a bit of a
risk i mean i know it's difficult to
talk about risk post pandemic but we
have there has to be some addressing of
the longer term issues of the of
productivity in this country rather than
playing around with a few pennies here
or there okay uh
i'm going to come to robin gillingham in
devon ella says that we should be
talking about growth and so on but robin
what's your view about
about this are we being too gloomy or
what do you think we should be talking
about
um basically we're finding that we've
got a small business grassroots level uh
that costs acro across the border just
keep rising annually and the only thing
we can do now is pass that cost on to
the end user
um you know we've absorbed as much as we
can margins are really tight there's
already so much you can do so it's
literally just got to be passed on don't
want to but that's the only way you can
survive
and then you having to compete with
these large corporations that probably
have a much better budget that can then
afford to pay better wages and probably
what the little small places can
and then you're having to compete
against them as well to try and remain
competitive and so it's really tricky
it's a fine balance
so is it your view that
the chancellor is wrong to raise the
living wage uh so sharply
i don't think he has much choice i think
an external influence has caused all of
this so all this inflation
you have to it's just a case of keeping
up and all we're doing is treading water
and so we're passing that costs on
hopefully their wages have gone up
slightly so they can afford it becomes
just a bit relative
okay paul johnson are we heading for
an inflation burst
well the increase in the minimum wage up
until now have been incredibly
successful it's gone up an awful lot
over the last
10 years and that doesn't appear to have
caused any problems with prices
or unemployment but going forward
there's a limit to this i think one of
the real worries is it seems to be the
only tool the government has at the
moment it's worried about people's
earnings it's worried about productivity
and the main policy appears to have is
just to keep on putting the national
living wage up and at some point as
you've heard from a couple of your
panelists that's going to cause
that's going to cause real problems in
terms of its impact on inflation what
really matters and i mean just to repeat
the point i suppose is
wages going up with productivity going
up in other words if we're paying people
more because they're doing more that's
fine that won't impact inflation but if
you keep pushing wages up when
productivity isn't going up then that
will in the end just result in higher
prices and that i think is the worry
across the board at the moment john bird
last last word you've spent a lifetime
worrying about
the least fortunate in society
what does this mean for them
well the interesting thing about our
economy which for since the time of the
victorians has been a low-wage economy
and if you have a low-wage economy then
you have people who when something like
the price of gas goes up really hits
them and i think the government what the
government is trying to do is move
people more to a higher wage economy now
at some stage if we want to have more
social opportunity and more
egalitarianism then we do need to move
to a higher wage economy a higher wage
economy that is as paul says linked to
higher productivity there is a joke that
goes around that if you pay
very very low wages then you will get
very very low
delivery and we have to move into a high
wage economy in my opinion i think the
government should be the one that picks
up this gap because it's the
government's responsibility to lift us
out of this hundreds of years of
low-wage economy okay thank you let's
just come back finally to the wall to
our viewers panel
i guess go back to i suppose the central
question let's give the chancellor some
advice
he hasn't uh
actually said we haven't heard it from
his mouth that he's going to
raise this national living wage so we're
pretty sure that's what's going to
happen is he right let's say who
amongst our viewers panel think that it
is right and we can afford that 6.6
increase can i see those in who think
it is right and we should afford it
well we're pretty clear
we think he can
and we should
okay that's it from us for tonight i
just want to say thank you to our
panelists in the studio paul johnson
emanuel asuko hello whelan and john byrd
and i want to thank you all on the wall
for your questions for your comments and
your lively presents we can see you so
thank you wave goodnight to our viewers
thank you so much and thank you to all
of you who've been watching at home
we'll see you again for next week's
great debate
you